hi my name is jenny martin and i'm the
director of cyber security
investigations at symantec
today cyber crime causes huge problems
for society personally financially and
even in matters of national security
just in the last few years hundreds of
millions of credit card numbers have
been stolen
tens of millions of social security
numbers and health care records were
compromised
even nuclear centrifuges have been
hacked and unmanned aerial drones have
been hijacked
this is all done by exploiting
vulnerabilities in hardware and software
or more often by taking advantage of
unintentional decisions made by the
people using the software
the people committing these cyber crimes
don't fit a single profile or motivation
it could be anyone from an international
terrorist to a teenager competing for
bragging rights
today the largest countries not only
have a regular army but also have a
well-armed cyber army in fact the next
world war may not be fought with
traditional weapons but with computers
used to shut down national water
supplies
energy grids and transportation systems
hi my name is parisa and i'm google's
security princess
i've worked on a lot of different google
products and a lot of different ways to
try and make our software as secure as
possible
now let's take a look at how cyber crime
works under the hood
we'll learn about software viruses
denial of service attacks and phishing
scams
in biology and life a virus is an
organism that is spread by coughing
sneezing or physical contact
viruses work by infecting cells
injecting their genetic material and
using those cells to replicate they can
make people really sick and then spread
to other people
a computer virus works a bit similarly
a virus is an executable program that
gets installed
usually unintentionally and harms a user
and their computer
it's also possible for a virus to spread
itself to other computers
now how does a virus get on your
computer in the first place
there are a couple ways an attacker can
infect someone's computer
they might lure a victim into installing
a program with deception about the
program's purpose
so for example a lot of viruses are
disguised as security updates
it's also possible that the software on
your computer has a vulnerability so an
attacker can install itself without even
needing explicit permission
once a virus is on your computer it can
steal or delete any of your files
control other programs or even allow
someone else to remotely control your
computer
using computer viruses hackers can take
over millions of computers worldwide
and then use them as a digital army
otherwise known as a botnet to attack
and take down websites
this kind of attack is called a
distributed denial of service
a denial of service is when hackers
overwhelm a website with too many
requests
we call it a distributed denial of
service when the attack comes from many
computers all at once
most websites are ready to respond to
millions of requests a day but if you
hit them with billions or trillions of
requests coming from different places
the computers are overloaded and stop
responding
another trick used by cyber criminals is
to send large amounts of spam email in
an attempt to trick people into sharing
sensitive personal information
this is called a phishing scam
a phishing scam is when you get what
seems like a trustworthy email asking
you to log into your account but
clicking the email takes you to a fake
website
if you log in anyway you've been tricked
into giving your password away
hackers can then use your login
credentials to access your real accounts
to steal information or maybe even to
steal your money
fortunately there are many companies
laws and government organizations
working to make the internet safer but
these efforts are not enough
you may think when a computer system
gets hacked the problem is the security
design or the software
ninety percent of the time a system gets
hacked however it's not because of a
security bug but because of a simple
mistake made by a human
it turns out there are steps we can all
take to protect ourselves
often your actions not only impact the
security of your own data and computer
but the security of everyone at your
school workplace and home
with billions or trillions of dollars at
stake cyber criminals get smarter each
year and we all need to keep up
you